good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this very first press conference
following the Foreign Affairs Council
for the first time chaired by High
Representative vice president of the
mohel the High Representative will
present you a few elements about what
has been discussed today and we will
have time for a few questions
High Representative please good
afternoon
well today was the first foreign affairs
council that I chair you know ready that
my work ahead will be guided by the
three principles realism unity on
partnership we need partners we need to
be united and you need to act into a
real world so I want to support for the
member state to give a fresh impulse to
the Foreign Affairs Council our meetings
must be the place where our collective
efforts come together to promote a more
effective EU foreign policy and you have
just finished a long discussion has been
long but profitable we exchanged our
priorities in the world head and how to
better work together to achieve the
objectives of the external action of the
European Union on the basis of the
letter that I sent to the ministers they
sent a letter to the Foreign Affairs
ministers and another to the defense
ministers because I thought that it was
better to send a letter that not to
spend three-quarters of an hour with a
long oral explanation today in the
Consul we have been dealing with current
affairs
which as you know are the most pressing
eat items on the international agenda we
have been dealing with Memorandum of
Understanding signed between Libya and
Turkey we discussed this and it's a very
clear from our discussion that this
document raises major concerns we
express our solidarity and our support
to Greece and Cyprus and we will
continue doing that you know that we
already deliver it a communication on
that issue and first thing was on last
week as soon as we knew about this
agreement Olivia more specifically the
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Germany
my Akuma's as you form the council about
the Germans plan for the Berlin process
which aims at finding a sustainable
solution to the situation in Libya I
hope you will bear fruit and I believe
we should be able to do more on Libya we
certainly do more because we cannot
claim to be a geopolitical power or
geopolitical commission if we cannot
solvent problems in our immediate
neighborhood we also touch upon Ukraine
and the normative for summit which is
taking place as we speak now in Paris I
think we have a positive momentum and
needs to be used it has been some
improvements on this engagement and I
hope that today some it will be another
step towards the sustainable and
peaceful solution to the conflict
I also I personally raised Iran because
on Friday we had the meeting of the
Joint Commission of the jcpoa Friday in
Vienna shared by the secretary-general
of the European external Action Service
which show that all participants stand
behind the agreement and want to
preserve it
this unanimous position is for us very
important all participants stand behind
the agreement and want to preserve it I
highlighted on a note just after the
meeting that to keep this agreement
alive is a collective responsibility but
unless the recent trend on the nuclear
side is not reverse it will not be
sustainable but the European Union and
all participants of the Friday meeting
in Vienna are very much standing behind
this agreement Bolivia since the very
beginning of the crisis the European
Union has been very active we have been
actively engaged and I want to thank the
European Union delegation and all
embassies of the European Union member
states for the work they have done and
we hope that the parties continue to
show moderation and complete the
transition and reconciliation process
through holding elections Bolivia as you
know is part of a wider worrying
situation in Latin America on the last
five years it hasn't been any high-level
meeting summit between European Union
and Latin American countries
anything this has to be correct
corrected and addressing this will be
one of the my priorities during my
mandate but the most important the most
pressing priority for us to they is the
relations with Africa in the agenda this
was one of the two items and we started
the work with the European Union foreign
ministers to discuss on how do we want
to shape our relationship with our
African partners in order to prepare the
2020 European Union African Union summit
we need a comprehensive strategy with
Africa when it appears things on Africa
they think of migration and demography
because they are we have watching images
of people arriving to the European coast
and people dying crossing the
Mediterranean for sure migration is one
of the most important issues we have to
deal with African neighbours but it's
not the only one and one thing is clear
we cannot have a strategy for Africa
without Africa this has to be something
that responds to an ownership among
Europeans but mainly with the Africans
the visit of the president of the
Commission to Addis Ababa this weekend
sends a strong message in this direction
we have to reach out our African
partners and I've been asking foreign
ministers to be fully engaged on this a
strong partnership on preparing this
partnership agreement
we will have a college to college
meeting with African Union Commission in
February in 2020 as agreed by President
Roh sort of underlying then we will have
a European Union African Union
ministerial meeting and at the end of
2020 we will have the summit in Brussels
so we have a clear path ahead of us for
this important work and they cancel at
this meeting and his meeting during this
week this week meeting it's on Thursday
will also send a clear signal giving a
mandate to the Commission and to the
High Representative to work on this
comprehensive and shared strategy for
Africa and with Africa the second point
in the agenda was human right this is an
issue that remains a clear priority for
the Europeans and it will be during my
mind date and it's very timely to talk
about it because tomorrow is the
International Human Rights Day and the
important thing is that under the
request of several member states we have
agreed to launch the preparatory work
for a global sanctions regime to address
serious human rights violations which
will be the European Union equivalent of
the so-called
Magnitsky act of the United States
I was asked for this issue in my
presentation in the Parliament last week
and today we have decided it was a
strong consensus about it to launch the
preparatory work and the European
external Action Service will prepare the
documentation for this in order to
prepare the equivalent of the
act this will be the tangible step
reaffirming the European Union global
late on global human rights member
states has also been informed and they
have showed a broad support for the new
action plan and human rights and
democracy that will be prepared by my
services for the next five years we will
present the proposal early next year as
you know this is a reference document on
human rights in the world it is a
document of reference and the new one
will all always be continued being
something unique on this kind worldwide
and in the land you have been talking
about how to improve the working methods
of the foreign affairs council we will
continue working on that but is mainly
content on the letter that I sent to the
ministers to prepare in the meeting
thank you very much we will now take a
few questions
I start with Nora didn't